[Music]
hello and welcome to sidetrack we are a
little late and stormy seems to have
fallen off his chair
but we had some technical issues with
the volume
and now i genuinely am worried the storm
is falling off your chair because you
were there a second ago storm oh i had a
[Laughter]
where did you go i only left you for 30
seconds and you ran away from me i
didn't right you can't leave me alone
for anything
no no
so we are in some audio issues we don't
seem to have fixed but um i will just
run along with it so is the audio still
back to being crappy
it's you're just a little quiet shelley
hi how are you doing the scene here
but we're not gonna worry about it
all right fine
so before we get into this week's topic
which is was sci-fi better before
cgi came in and ruined everything um
what you've been watching this week
stormy
well this week i finished up
uh discovery star trek discovery
and the uh 10c the the the first
encounter of the 10c species
kind of
interesting uh
i
i kind of like the way how the
the tennessee
used
pheromones and kind of mathematics to uh
speak to each other that was kind of
that that was the cool thing for me
okay
um
i haven't watched any of it oh you
haven't oh no
and now we discussed this couple weeks
ago but it's it's all quickly on in the
uk that i actually have to watch it when
it's on
right and i can't record it because it's
on this um pluto it's not yeah it's on
some sort of it's not not a street and i
just can't be bothered to watch tv
whenever you insist i watch it i'll
watch it when i want to watch it damn it
so i didn't watch it
sounds very cute niche to me
yeah
forcing you to watch your star trek at
specific time
yeah yeah exactly we don't live in
communist russia damn it
um but uh but yeah no i've not watched
it at all
i did watch the third episode of picard
um
a little disappointed
well really after a great start
getting a little boring
but um i wandered off at one point my
brain just wandered off at one point now
i've come back like no something's
happened
um but but yeah it's not too bad
anything else anything else caught your
eye this week while we were
well i kind of like i kind of liked the
latest episode of
car episode three
you know i like once they get into um
los angeles 2024
you know they're they're still busting
uh hispanic people
at the doctor's office you know it's
it's just like you know because i live
right outside of l.a
and it's like yeah boy that they nailed
that period piece correct
then they started happening on about
world war three
yeah well yeah it's just like they
mentioned it
is it any wonder world war three came
you know did it why did it take so long
for all this angst to work itself out
you know hey cat story
and it was like
that was it was i uncanny you know it's
just like
i couldn't watch sky news the rest of
the night you know it was just i had to
cut myself off preston as hell yeah
a little bit accurate isn't it
i said the other thing that i watched
that will will smoothly you're going to
like this segway it's smooth into this
week's topic
i watched faster the furious 9 this week
i also watched sorry i did before
getting to that i watched the adam
project with ryan reynolds i liked that
was it good yeah very spielbergy
right um but that's not a bad thing let
me say that like it's a bad thing it's
not um it's not his best work but good
film very enjoyable little sci-fi movie
i'm sure
i'm not sure it's a classic but you know
good film quite enjoyed it
um but yes i did i watched fast and
furious nine
it's two hours i'm not getting back
um i like the fast and the furious
movies they're good films you know
they're popcorn movies you know they're
brain off
popcorn in face
don't think about this
um
yeah exactly um
but the ninth one
is just what they've done is they've
gone physics physics is a bit boring
let's not bother with that
and gravity gravity is a pain let's not
worry about that
and um cars can survive in space right
elon musk shot went into space so
carson's space right
that's true
yeah so they just they just went with
that
and seriously there was a car in space
for a good chunk of the movie
um and they drove it into a satellite
um it's the stupidest film i've ever
seen
um
are you sure you weren't watching
moonraker
it sounds like you're watching moonraker
no i think somebody slipped something
into my coffee
because what i was watching made no
sense at all i'm like am i seeing this
[ __ ] it's uh and it's awful um no i'm
not gonna watch it just because it's so
crappy
yeah but it's it's not like it's so bad
not like last week's movie go back and
let's check out last
last two weeks ago live show and we
talked about films they're so bad
they're great this is just bad
and it's just bad um it's not you know
this you get those films that are that
it's so stupid they're hilarious i think
it's not that
it's not that um and it takes itself
very very seriously um but honestly i
don't i don't want to read it for
anybody that watches it because i mean
it is a popcorn movie you're not
supposed to think about it too much but
if you do think at all
you will drive yourself up the wall
at any point you'll go is that possible
it isn't
it's like it's just stupid
but that gets us into this like they say
the little the smooth segway because
this is all thought out were films
better before cgi
overtook everything
you know when when they had to actually
have physical
special effects and when they actually
had to
do these things in like
carve calm
think about there's the james bond um
movie right where you know they have to
do this thing and they have to jump the
car over the river right um
and it took them ages to do because they
had to build this ramp just right
spiraled around a viral thing and then
jumped and then landed right it took
loads of effort nowadays they'd just
done that cgi and it probably would have
done a backflip in it it would have
landed like this sort of thing like
gymnast on the it would have done some
nonsense you know um
but
they had to do it back in the day and i
think it
the effort paid off you know um nowadays
they just do it in cgi
we're going to talk about old movies
like pre-1990s movies in a minute but
another example is
the um
nic cage movie gone in 60 seconds
right yeah yeah didn't that also have
angelina jolie in it it had the
beautiful angelina jolie and the
excellent actor vinnie jones who who how
that man has not got an oscar i don't
know
um he's probably met somebody called
oscar
um but he has not got one of the gold
little statues but um in that movie
there is a bit at the end where they
have to jump the shelby on a bridge and
they used cgi
but they did it on cgi because if they
got it even an inch wrong
if they're on if they're on a thickened
bridge it would have you know um a
suspension bridge it would have shredded
the car like you know
a cheese crater
so they had to do it cgi the rest of the
film is physical
you know physical special effects with
actual driving
that bit in the movie sticks out like
you'd hammered your thumb with a
you know it's like sticks out like a
sore thumb it's awful
for me that really is an example you
know
you know a great film ruined by well not
ruined because it's still a great film
but that bit sticks out you know
well the uh one of the things um
um thurman
in a batman robin
and she played poison ivy
and when she she's uh i think in the
first scene as poison ivy she's kind of
draped black back in this uh plant in
this bloom the petals just unwrap and
there's kind of a sparkly mist coming
down on her
and the the petals just open up and they
they illuminate
and one thing that she remarked i don't
know if this is in the um
if i saw this in an interview or it's on
the special dvd features or whatever
but she was talking about about how none
of that was cgi
it was all classic
physical effects in the lens
and she said when did uh batman come out
batman said like
ninety people said oh it's gonna be
midnight
97
97 37
and she said that just doesn't that's
just not done anymore you know even back
then she's going to just put in a
computer and then it's done and she said
it was all done by puppeteers and it's
just like maybe a dozen people working
on that just to get it to look right you
know there's a puppeteer there's the
physical effects guys with the whatever
the illuminated powder was and then
there's the lighting guys
and you know and that is
real craftsmanship and sometimes i'm
agreeing with you that
i think that's a lost art and it's not
really i mean it can be replicated
digitally but
that's on the high end of special
effects it's not the middle of the road
you know we haven't gotten that kind of
skills there yet for like most
productions i mean i mean you get some
obviously some cgi of the first avatar
film i said right because we're about to
have nine
um but the avatar movie amazing but but
i think that was it was the cgi is kind
of the point isn't it anymore
obviously
um
jurassic park the first jurassic park is
30 years old and i saw i saw it at the
cinema during the pandemic because i've
seen new films were being released so my
local cinema sort of showed die hard i
actually got to see die hard at the
cinema which is just
just loved it
um i missed predator predator was on and
i didn't get to see it
um but um jurassic park was on and i'm
watching it again this one's 30 years
old and it still looks insane it's still
so good
um so
but then you get special effects like in
the second matrix movie or you know when
they're overly ambitious
that they try to do an effect that
doesn't work and it just looks like
claiming
if you're british they look like morph
british people watching will know what i
mean
you won't know what i'm talking about
but um you know there's it looks like a
clay puppet sort of thing it just looks
shocking
but that goes back to the question then
so were films better
when they didn't have that
i think they had to work at it a little
bit more
you know
because it's uh
because now they're expecting you know
well
some kid fresh out of film school can
probably do this in 10 minutes you know
so they shoot it not really worrying
about it
and they don't really and because they
just
feel and i really think
special effects is becoming like a film
commodity almost like the
you know the uh
people at the craft services truck you
know i think they're
the above the line folks oh that's just
special effects let's just we'll hire
somebody
and
i think one thing you see with um
like jim cameron you know how he he
really crafts the story and
um especially in titanic how he used the
special physical effects and special
effects blended together for that movie
it was just it was really stunning even
to this day what that movie is
12 years old
i was i was my early 20s when that film
came out she's going to be at least 22
23 years old
yeah
comments tell us when it was made
another james cameron move that i think
is a really good example of how he mixed
cgi very early cjos the abyss
where he used elements of cgi in that
film but he used it very sparingly
because he knew what he was capable of
with physical effects again you know so
um
this the submerged rig thing was a model
and a lot of those models but then when
the water came up that was one of the
very but that mean but that film was
i've got it on my list actually
uh
1989
yeah
1989 i was living in
1988 i was living in huntington beach
california and i had a contract job as a
freelancer for a company called
precision effects in semi valley and i
got to work on the deep dive suit and
for the abyss
no
i did not know that yes i brought it up
and uh yeah it was uh
when i was there at semi it was like uh
there was abyss
there was um
die hard
two i think it was the one with the dc
airport that worked on these boxes you
know um
there was like the the the the military
comes in with all these communication
boxes we just kind of threw that
together
and what was the other one i worked on
it was um
sylvester stallone sandra bullock
oh the where he's the
oh he's the bomber and stuff isn't he's
the assassin
no no no that's not sandra bullock
that was um that was sean stone
oh there's one he goes he he's uh
um he he's getting he's frozen kind of
in his prison and they follow him out to
uh demolition demolition man right right
there's these uh
um
there's these statues in the hall of
pain i think it was
and we got to dress those uh mannequins
and we had to take uh physical models
for the we had to implaster
the uh those models and we had to dress
them with whatever
um uniform that was dude you worked on
general classic genuine classic
hollywood movies i mean you actually had
your hands on some of these things that
is really cool and i did not know that
about you
i like you even more now than i did five
minutes ago i still have my uh work
badge when i worked i was the film
loader was a film tech for uh batman the
original batman
this this live show was just taking a
completely different and
then i moved back to the west coast
because it was like okay so the reason i
left that
is there was a 4.8
earthquake like under my feet
i was living in this apartment building
and then i i didn't feel anything i
heard this loud damn bang
and then there's another one that got
closer is above me then another bang got
closer and is above me then there's
another bang that was under my feet and
everything that was on my uh like my um
bathroom countertop just went whoosh
plop
then i felt the earthquake it was the
pressure joints in the apartment
building
pop so the building wouldn't
tumble over
then all the cars alarm car alarms went
off and then a block party broke out
now it's like a 4.8 and everyone's
celebrating there's a frisbee toss going
he's like this is [ __ ] insane
so then i'm sorry what did you do on
batman though to go back away from the
earth what did you go back oh i was a
film tech i just managed film reels and
loaded uh film cartridges
nothing
that's one of the the highest grossing
movies of all time
and you've frozen
um are you back um and you got to work
on that that is incredible
didn't meet anybody
no he didn't get to to tickle michael
keaton like two or three weeks
straight
amazing though to be even even just to
even be around it that's incredible it
was crazy i mean yeah
yeah
and after that went back to north
carolina and made independent films
for about another and through like 96
and i said [ __ ] this [ __ ] and then i
went back and then i just went into
advertising
amazing
okay well we'll get back to the topic
because you just blow my mind
um
but
i i always think that the films
particularly i mean you you've got a
look at really old sci-fi movies i mean
really old sci-fi movies even less like
the day the earth stood still or
something like that it is a good example
some of those special effects because
they were
so hard to do
were great i mean that the defined
source of coming in over the white house
not having you know um
it looked real you know and it was in
the 50s
um
you know i love that
we are getting to a point now with cgi
you can't tell
what's real and what's not i mean it's
it is getting that good
um
you know i i mean it's even getting into
tv now you know you
would mention star trek card earlier the
queue where he comes in he's he's got
they do that young thing and then he
just goes i'll catch you up
um
the first time i saw it i thought that
was a bit rubbish i should have done
that and i've actually watched it again
back and i'm like oh actually that's
quite good
they've done quite a good job with that
very seamless
yeah yeah um the
skywalker obviously in the first series
hey mike how you doing hello
skywalker when they made him young
looked a bit creepy at the end of the
first season of mandalorian but in boba
fett they've got it right
yeah
good
but then i think about
i've just started watching daredevil
again
um
big marvel fan and
there i've just because i've started
watching it with my sons it's on disney
plus now i've started like my sons are
at an age i think you can watch it now
um and we just watched the second
episode and there's this fight sequence
um when he's going down a corridor and
it's cinema level of choreography it's
it's one of the greatest spy sequences
ever put on film
um and there's not a cgi inside because
they were they they did it for real you
know and there's a lot of filmmakers
that actually have started to do that um
seth rogen he did a tv series
called preacher
and the start of the sequence to start
this um of the the series there's this
like rocket ship and it's like
you know sparkles come out the back and
stuff
um and it looks like an old 1950s really
crappy movie you know like the um flash
gordon series or something and it looks
like that and it crashes on the earth or
whatever and he says they wanted to do
that for real they wanted to you know
put it on get a model on fireworks
and he said it would actually but he
ended up cgi in it because he said it
would have actually cost more to do with
physical
effects than it cost just to cgi
um i mean like i said you know i think
it's you know effects now becoming a
commodity
you know as like the like the craft
service truck
yeah i think that's a little sad
it is it is
you know um
if like great films though back back in
the day
predator for me is is one of those
movies that's just perfect right there's
literally nothing
wrong with that film and there's
virtually no cgi in that movie um it's
it's
green screen and they actually
physically draw on the
on the on you know on the um on the film
basically you know it's very physical
effects yeah um but that film still
stands up today because they kept the
effects as simple as possible sort of
thing
a lot of the effects you know like the
the predator and all the different ways
he envisioned something
that's just in camera
uh typically in camera filters
or it was just
you know like the heat map or something
that's just
you know actual video
yeah that's just actual video from an
actual heat seeking or a heat
a heat sensitive camera and then turned
over to uh played in the film
you know and uh so
again i think
and years ago you know before the 90s or
whatever
filmmakers had to find ways
to make it uh look really good with what
they had and so they became more
creative
i think it makes
storytellers lazier though with cj
because again if we use the predator
example there's obviously been lots of
predator movies since i actually think
predator 2 is a bit like die hard 2 that
you mentioned earlier if it wasn't for
die hard 2 is a great movie in it but
it's always compared to die hard so it's
always sort of like gonna look you know
it's not got that same thing predators
predator 2 is always going to be you
know compared to predator and it's just
not it doesn't stand up
even though on its own it's a brilliant
movie but predators that came out not
long ago um
is
i see the last one isn't terrible then
it at the end is awful and he basically
gets this alien predator suit and he
goes oh let's go let's go fight some
predators it's just a crap in
um but um
i i just feel like it makes them lazy
because it's almost like
the effect becomes more important than
the story it's like look what clever
thing we can do
when the film
seems to
go around that
matrix is an example the first matrix
the
couple of effects like bullet speed all
right and then the um the effect when
they're in the corridor and they shoot
the crap out the reception
and
those were big parts of the movies but
the movie was built around it and it was
you know it wasn't the blind it seemed
it feels to me like other films have
come along then let's go right we've got
this special effect
no one's ever seen this before
so now let's let's just make up the
movie comes second that feels like
sometimes
a lot of that is uh true i mean
let's say let's go back to the pre-90s
thing before we had all these effects
studios would get scripts that were
i mean the writers just went whole hog
and they were so outlandish there's no
budget to even make it in physical or
special effects
yeah it just just wasn't
so writers if they want to be successful
they had to write around the technology
that was available
and so
when jurassic park came out
i mean people went hog wild and if you
look at
cgi heavy cgi movies after jurassic park
proved okay this is what you can do
then those those heavy cgi movies went
up and up and up the number of
productions per year went up really up
and i think
um
i think there's you know
there's always been a lot of scripts
being written that were just impossible
to shoot at the time you know
um but now i think takes technology as a
re as it has risen and become popular
and affordable
now you've got every kind of schlock
show
you know
oh yeah let's see sharknado yeah let's
have like 10 of those
flying sharks sharks with tentacles
sharks on a golf course yes sharknado
this time it's all personal
is that because they cover the lack of
imagination though then is it is it like
it seems to me as well we always get
bursts of movies that come along
particularly in sci-fi
and that when something if something
hits then you'll see three or four
movies suddenly made i've got about the
same subject
um within a few years of each other
um
[Music]
armageddon comes along and then deep
impact a year later suspiciously and you
know all these sorts of things it seems
to happen quite a lot
um
there's a some nano tech is mentioned in
the movie and then awesome for the next
two years it's all it's mentioned in
sci-fi movies so that was populous let's
just do that
um do you think that is a problem with
everything
it's it's a safety thing you know that
something works they just think well
let's just do that again then
well yeah i mean i know writers that
just
look through wired magazine every month
looking for stuff to write about
like
you know
wordsmith some sort of story together
based on whatever the cover is or
whether the future story is wired
magazine every month
you know
yeah and i there are a lot of directors
like saying um john favreau says done
here that are trying to actually step
come away from cgi time so i'm trying to
do the physical they're very proud of
the fact that when they do something
physical
um in the new um
uh tom cruise movie uh the michelin
possible film he does a halo jump which
is a high altitude low open jump
but he actually did it
there was the director there was no
reason to do it i think because tom
cruise is tom cruise he just thought i
want to do it i didn't want to do it but
they did the physical they actually did
it and it took them about three months
apparently
kept practicing again another tom cruise
example top gun they said there's not a
lot of cgi in that film we fly the
planes you know we actually do and it's
because it's better it looks better
i i don't think that they'll ever get to
a point though that when cgi doesn't
matter how cgi how good it gets
you can tell
and i think that takes a little bit away
from the movie
i think about um
well here's a film that's been made over
and over and over again um invasion of
the body snatches
and that that's a that's a a great film
that's been made
or you know stolen or you know the the
the basic plot's been reused over and
over and over again
i don't think it was ever done better
than um you know like the 1978 version
um
the thing
with kurt russell is a similar sort of
sort of thing the special effects
um even though you could you know
they just added something to the movie
because it was
on the screen you know it was actually
well for one thing john carpenter is no
slouch you know
kurt russell did a really good job
and
the use of darkness like almost like an
underdeveloped print or underdeveloped
uh film to get some of the creepiness
into it
that's a really cheap thing i mean
hitchcock did it all the time
and going back into
like you know uh physical effects versus
a cgi you're mentioning
um
i think uh one of the double o seven
model uh movies earlier
i feel which one but uh
anyway
with i think it was casino royale they
actually rolled that austin martin 11
times physically that makes me want to
cry
and uh
so that at least they're ruling cars
you know um
but i do think it's a dying art there's
one movie that uh bert reynolds burt
reynolds did a lot of his own driving
stunts in all of his movies and there's
one called hooper that he did that was
all about stunt drivers
you know and how they were playing breed
and la da da da da
where he was just over the hill kind of
a stunt driver
excuse me and
like in the remakes you know like the
thing
there's a lot of the remakes are just
sad
um
that's a good example um
cole check the knife stopper oh yeah you
remember the original uh gavin what's
this let's see
what was his name
[Music]
uh darren mcgavin right he was the lead
star
it was really good you know um
his acting writing was really good then
they came out with
uh
a remake of it
the remake was crap
i mean there was no soul to it i mean it
was you know cgi flashy stuff
and i remember the creepiest thing seen
in the original night stalker with uh
with mcgavin was
there was like an abandoned i don't
remember the episode that well because i
i saw it as a child i've been
traumatized since and so i haven't seen
it again
but it was like it was a
an abandoned chicago
um
hospital right and it was haunted by
something and mcgowan and uh coal shacks
trying to get an image of it right so
and they thought it was like an is like
berry is like built on top of an ancient
a native american burial ground maybe
so then he gets all these x-ray films
right and tapes them on the wall as he
tries to i'm going to trap the spirit or
something
and then when
everything is over with and he's
successful and of course he doesn't have
a story he
pays together all the the films and it's
like an image of one eye
with like a trailing tear
and it spooked me out oh my god it was
just what
i can't go in the basement for three
years because of that
that just sounded really creepy
no special effects
nothing
done on a 16 millimeter uh camera
great storytelling no thinking about
like a mainstream move there's a bit
like this the first player which and
that's that's another good example they
had no money so they did it
in that um
found videotape style which always
creeps in there there's an alien one
that was similar we found this videotape
because that would creep me out as well
um blair which scared me to death i was
um
18 or 19 or something like that with my
brothers who'd watched it um and we were
like we had to walk home through woods
so we walked about a mile out of our way
so we didn't have to walk through these
woods
we're growing we're laughing about it
the whole way we're grown men we should
walk through the world and we're like oh
yeah let's not um but that was all
physical but then blair witch the second
one came out they had more money
yeah they
bulked up the special effects and thing
and it's it's a terrible movie um i
think there's a lot to say about
what what movie makers i like to paint
and things
and one of the things we saw with
painting is it's knowing when to stop
and it's knowing what not to paint
right so it's what you don't add is more
important than what you do and that's a
really important point with movie making
as well as what you don't have don't
show the bad guy too soon
you know don't show if it's a ghost
movie you've got to build the tension up
and when you see the
ghost
that's when it tends to go to nl if you
if you see the ghost too soon you know
um and and that's the same in any
monster movie you know i think you've
got to build it up build it up it's what
you don't put in but cgi lets them just
seem to go crazy with it they can put in
anything when you can do anything
and you put it in the hands of a
um you know or you know story that maybe
isn't that great or
um it's like um i think sharknado was
basically made it was a bit like um
snakes on a plane
yeah see that with samuel jackson it was
a meme and then it was a movie
yeah oh what did the um the the producer
i don't think it was weinstein but it's
somebody like that um he hadn't even
read the script
he basically said we want to make i'm
going to make a movie what's the
stupidest title we've got in the things
and they went we've got a script called
snakes on a plane and like done
and and again read the script and he
greenlit
to be made um and sam jackson they got
sam jackson to do it he was on contract
to do a film so he didn't have a choice
and it's actually
quite a good film
um but it got me because it had a stupid
title and it was it was sort of like
that that's what that's what kind of my
point is so sometimes these films get
made not because they're a great story
but because there's some sort of gimmick
and too much to me seems to the gimmick
is what special effect is new we've got
this new special effect we can do so
let's just
do that um
that's a good point so what do we think
about the 2004 battlestar galactica
specialist specs cgi versus 1970 1978
i think that's a really good point i i
like that um i'm sorry
joe jim i'm sorry i got struggled with
your name i'm gonna call you joe
um
but i i think that's quite a good
example actually of good special effects
so because the battlestar galactica
effects were very very good and they
were very very subtle
um
[Music]
you couldn't i i for me i don't think
you could really tell the difference
between the physical effects or the
or the cgi what do you think
well they won awards for the special
effects
yeah under the original pentastar
galactica
um essentially that was uh
the same crew that did start all the
special effects for star wars was it
trumbull's gang was it
it did
yeah they just well let's go do this for
like it was abc
you know so it was the same crew
essentially
and the same technology so yeah those
were you know still in not the special
effects were still in camera effects and
affiliate printing and models and so
forth and so on
and
the i think the
the battlestar galactica
series that uh came out in
2004 i guess
um
i thought
the special effects
were really good a lot of the cgi was
really good because it was so restrained
that's yeah it was subtle yeah you know
the the the advancements the the the um
the things that were weak
were
uh the new robots
you know
yeah cause they they had the um the
cylons yeah yeah they were a little bit
i thought
you know they they i don't know they
didn't flex like they were in a in
gravity they just kind of started and
stopped and
i don't know i know i'd agree with that
issue to be fair and they um
because maybe they went a bit they
wanted to take the the original style
from the series but then take it and
next step in this they wanted to but
but i suppose that was the point of it
but that was you know but the one that
maybe they they went a bit too far with
but i mean i think that the special
effects the cgi in that particular like
you said it was restrained
it was
again it was what they didn't put into
it that was so good that the lack of
sound you know whether whether you used
silence
um
and because you can't hear a scream in
space you know sort of thing so um
again the way they use that but they
kept it
really subtle which which i really loved
and that's exactly my point of things
when cgi is is a very very
powerful tool
when it's used
carefully particularly in cgi
um right yeah
we're talking about um
snakes on a plane and how just a mean
can become a movie
um
jerry seinfeld made this movie called b
movie b-e-e was like little bow
well the um
the way that started out was
uh
he was a he was a having dinner or
something with spielberg and he just he
it was a joke he said oh let's make a
movie called b movie but instead of
being a b movie it's about bees
in seinfeld's i mean uh still spielberg
said that's a great idea go for it
and it's made it up left and there's
jerry sandville going
i was joking
and
then he you know got a script and became
a kids movie and
it was decent it was good it's quite
good
um
but yeah i think like if i go back to
like the invasion of the body snatchers
example i gotta say they did the 78
version and then they did a version a
few years later the faculty which
doesn't have a lot of um cgi that was
good but they did a version
uh i can't believe what it's called
cause it wasn't called invasion body
snatches but again it was very much cgi
but they had the big reveal really early
on you know and it was like and it's
just
it's just
so much is taken away from the movie
because of that
um
filmmakers i just i just feel like
filmmakers are so lazy nowadays
um
that they don't they don't
i don't know they don't put the effort
in that they did
because they don't have to you know it's
like um
star wars the original star wars movie
um i i don't know if this is a trick but
i'm not pretty sure it's it's it's
genuine um i saw it on facebook so i
know i always mistrust everything i see
on facebook as a rule
um but there's a shop where um it's the
space port and darth vader's arriving at
the um death star for the first time
and it comes in in lands and there's
hundreds of stormtroopers
um and it looks like a perfect set but
it's actually painted it's it's a
painting basically and then then it cuts
to the shuttle and and stuff and things
get off because they didn't have that
many stormtroopers so they couldn't
create the effect
and so he
this is like painted on glass
yeah
and that is insane you cannot tell i'm
look i saw a photo of the guy doing it
and you still can't tell it's because it
was done so beautifully i'm trying to
think of the guy that it was is more or
less is a composted image you know the
uh film is
is uh show
they take the original
footage
project it through the back of the glass
and then you get the and then film the
the image therefore off of that
i can't remember the name of the guy man
he did like every 80s and 90s thing he's
like
uh
using that process especially for
spielberg
another example this is the same guy
i wish i could remember
uh
if one of the viewers could like google
and try to figure out who this guy was
but
uh indiana jones and the temple of doom
they've fallen out of the sky gotten out
of the river and they're walking up to
the palace
palace is all you know it's uh it's all
glass cotton it's a glass painting and
they're walking carefully beside the the
edge of the rail
because that because that's actually
in camera that's actually real but the
rest of it is all just you know just a
painting but the actors had to walk
close to the rail
not to get
their arm clipped off by the well the
painting
you mentioned indiana jones i think
that's a really good example of when
movie makers just go
crazy right um just go crazy with
effects if you think the difference
between
temple of doom
where they had some crazy stuff but they
had to build it like the the mine tunnel
right and things like this um and the
bridge and all this stuff but they had
to actually physically do it to a point
with special effects with models and
everything else but they had to do it
and then you think about the crystal
skull
and the one of the stupidest scenes in a
movie i've ever seen with the giant
killer ants that seem to be able to
outrun the car somehow
um
it's just
it was just stupid but even even
spielberg you know in that case got
seduced by what was possible maybe with
the cgi and went way too far
um
talk about really old movies did they
make a blog movie in 1998
i didn't see that i missed that
i've seen the original
sorry joe i didn't see you mate i'll
have to i'm gonna have to have a look
leftover chat about that next time i
didn't see it
um
other film that that i think was ruined
at least in part by cgi but who should
never been allowed to be made in the
first place was they when they did a
remake of charlie the chocolate factory
and again this isn't sidetrack this
isn't sci-fi at all but you have a
beautiful movie with gene wilder
where everything is was built and
constructed and everything you know
touch and then they make a weird remake
with johnny depp and use loads loads of
special effects and cgi and it's just
odd the whole film is weird
and but that was bad writing as much as
anything else to be fair you can't
really blame the cgi for that
but um
but by the way the guy that did the
matte paintings for all these movies
the guy's name is peter ellenshaw peter
ellenshaw it'd been her
you know and all the way up to titanic
and then when he
when um
a lot of cgi came about he switched to
digital
mapping
peter ellenshaw there's a video on a
youtube documentary about him i think
it's about an hour long really really
good like
the other thing he did
indiana jones uh the last scene
were this guy's got this box and he's
rocking it through this warehouse going
to put the ark of the covenant somewhere
that is that guy's matte painting
that and that's a painting
yeah yeah you can tell that couldn't be
real because it's just vast
but um but yeah i don't the skill in
that is beautiful um
that that was a technique or very
similar to a technique disney used to
use foods early
over layers
of um
yeah they had a five-layer camera
yeah they used for animation which was
great
i um joe's just come back it was 1988
they did a blob movie i do vaguely
remember that coming out actually um i
think i did watch it back then but yeah
no not a good film i'm afraid
um
another film that talked about how
terminator
so the first terminator was um
released in 1984 obviously another james
cameron brilliant so obviously the
special effects
in that movie were all physical there's
no cgi in that so the bit where he has
to mess with his eye and stuff they had
a big fake head you could tell it was a
fake
head and you know the thing would pull
inside and stuff and then you put some
glasses on just to cover it up um but
i i think that film stands up pretty
much
against anything we do today but then as
they've gone on they've got steadily
worse
is that at least in part because the cgi
or is it
you know because they're able to do
anything so they just do i mean even
terminator 2 a lot of the special
effects in there were physical and then
he you know brought in
elements of the cgi which again would
have never been done before but even the
the bit with the um
where it's the melting metal and all
started coming together again that
wasn't cgi that was a physical
um
specialist yeah it was just like you
know actually i think it's mercury on a
board and guys with like
blow dryers from you just kind of
moving literally just moving this stuff
or was it hot solder one of the other
i think it was solder
yeah yeah but yeah um because i thought
it was mercury and that was quite
surprised to find out it wasn't
what's on it
but
that's in the hands of jim cameron
not another not slouchy director
and but there's so much crap that comes
out that you know even netflix won't
even bother to put on
i think it's like studios
or content managers now struggling to
find a new franchise
so they will i mean they'll throw
anything against the wall and see what
sticks just to develop a new franchise
so they can have
another thousand or two movies you know
and just in the hope that something will
stick yeah netflix will show anything
uh absolutely anything
two weeks will show anything
um i remember there's um there's a
remake of dungeons and dragons
coming out right within chris pine based
on the board game and he said it's going
to be a mix between like the holy grail
and lord of the rings
and uh i want to see a mix between holy
grail and lord of the rings um
come back i'll bite your ankles off
um i just i wanted that that's a great
movie um
but i actually quite like the one from
like 20 years ago with jeremy irons and
uh
the weird little kid one of the wayans
brothers was in it
massively overacted there's one bit when
the main actor um uh the weigh-in guy is
killed
um his mate and he literally drops to
his knees and just goes no
it's gloriously awful and jeremy irons
is really creepy in a bit camp all the
way through
but wonder is this but that that movie
just basically got made because um one
big cgi company was a new cgi company
back when this was all kicked off and
they basically did the special effects
for free
and because they wanted to show off what
they could do so the whole big dragon
fight sequence was actually pretty cool
particularly considering the age
was done that was the only way they
could make the move they agreed
basically to take a kick of the prophets
sadly there weren't any
because they're all bombed
um
but you know that that those example of
like
what was happened back then that that
film basically only got made because the
cgi company wanted to show off what it
could do
you want to use
some skull but teensy worthy scuttlebutt
on that set of dungeons and dragons just
like when i start getting you breaking
up a little bit
do you want to hear some scuttlebutt tmz
worthy scuttlebutt from that movie
dungeons and dragons go for it
gary geigs
really didn't get along with jeremy
irons
at all
guy gax if if you've ever met him is
vivacious and blah blah blah blah blah
you know as always chatty chatty chatter
chatted chatty
irons was just like
he goes to the set says his line goes
the trailer
just that's that's all he does
you know and uh
guyax is he's very unsettled about he
said oh my god he was such a jerk
the baby
he was i don't know if he got to the
movie and discovered this is going to
suck or what but i mean his acting was
good but he just didn't associate and
this is again gygax's
overly bubbly personality that just
wants to hug everybody
um whether consensually or not just
no i have heard that jeremy islands did
not want to do that movie he did it for
the paycheck
they paid him a lot of money
so he did it um but yeah it's it's not
it's i i love it because it is one of
those films it's so bad it's great
i liked it yeah i loved it i i thought
it was great fun um i was always ashamed
i didn't get a sequel to be honest but
um and the kid that's in it he was in
something before that in a tv show and i
was quite liked him as an actor
and and uh i said i can't remember his
name but um
he i i i never saw him anything else
again ever and i was sort of kind of
ashamed i was quite liked
um
but yeah we're getting a sequel of that
anyway
so let's see what happens with that
i saw one really clever idea for the
next dungeons and dragons show or movie
or series or whatever
is that you have like five basic actors
and let's say one of the player
characters dies
you know the same actor plays the new
part
instead of a wizard it could be like you
know i don't know the old
sage you meet on the road or something
or a barbarian or something it's the
same actor and no one explains it it's
just
it goes from playing a gnome to a
barbarian or something and that would be
like keeping with the game
yeah let's just roll something up see
what happens
i actually suspect the dungeons and
dragons movie is going to be terrible um
and they will do what they always do in
these memories and they will reference
the game in some really cheesy way
and and it'll it'll again it'll it'll
really stand out in the movie and i'll
want to hurt myself
and
physically hurt myself um i did a video
a couple of weeks ago and i talked about
how do you remember they did a um
actually oh something here we talked
about it might been here we talked about
they did a thunderbirds movie a few
years ago
and jonathan freight's directed it
and jonathan freight should be kicked
repeatedly in the balls for us
um it's awful but in one bit the guy
that used to be an er
i can't i don't know his name i never
watched the show but he's been here at
one point the bad guy sticks like a
microchip in the back of his head
and controls him like a remote control
but he goes
and walks around like that it's like
back to the
how do you [ __ ] up the thunderbirds
movie
wow
it's really easy
i'm telling you the best thunderbirds
movie
was uh what was this world police
i'll only make love to you if you
promise you'll come back
and now that headquarters for cocktails
international science to help me here
yeah
team america i mean that's the best
underwear
that was again that's a film that they
did using physical effects it's almost
like we script these things
like we've been doing with cgi now
yeah
i think
showing
yeah i think this the south parks were
better when they actually had to do it
with bits of paper and you know motion
captions i think the early sandbox are
much better and then they actually like
they fake it with computer graphics
again because it's quicker and cheaper
to do that um and uh
shame really it's a it's a lot of these
dying art so man i always think about
like jim henson i like the muppets and
they and the effects like that you know
they would talk about um remaking their
labyrinth
yeah um
and and i just i don't think they should
do it um because
you know for one david bowie's not in it
and david bowie should be in everything
um i think he was on my list of films
the man that fell to earth was on my
list of films you know pre-90s films
sci-fi movies that would just still
stand up today still look amazing
but um but they won't have the jim
henson
puppets and things in it and because
it'll be easier and quicker to do cgi
and they can do more with cgi so they'll
do it that way and it'll be
just something
you know it's a lot of people panned the
new dark crystal series that came out
like
uh like his last year or during coba or
sometime
i thought it was really good because it
was still puppets you know and i think
uh and this the the story was good the
the acting was good the thing i think is
people are so used
to
cgi and all this fancy stuff is like
they couldn't
get back to the puppetry you know they
look old
yeah like forescape
loved scott of
uh foreskin of course and that was jim
henson as well jiminson as well business
he would have been his son then but you
know
yeah of course
yes i forgot about that that was great
um
think about that they do that in
stargate now something they think about
the um the character in discovery the
the the number two off gun his name he
was the captain in series two and that's
just three
um the tall fella
oh he always knows long legs
and things
yeah yeah a physical effect that looks
incredible um actually well then then
the cgi bits that
come out that that doesn't look super
and you know but they'll have character
thing like that they don't do that um i
think about stargate with the asgard you
know you can tell when it's the cgi
asgard in the later series or when it's
just the puppet in the other series and
it looks better
i think the actors interact with it
better the acting's better when they're
not interacting with a tennis ball on a
stick
you know and they're actually yeah
well frank oz in uh
and when he's doing uh when he's doing
yoda
you know
i mean you know lucas said this is all
going to rise or fall on the basis of a
plastic puppet
yeah no it's just
but
then they said
watch that film again with fresh eyes
and just
hamel and
frank oz's hand
pull it off and i think that's just
talent and skill you know but um i do
think there's a there's an argument to
say that the acting
is better when there's something
physically in front of you you know so
you see actors nowadays they say when
they go to the premiere and they see the
movie that's the first time they've seen
it
because all they did was stood in front
of a green screen and acted with a
tennis ball and it's literally a tennis
ball
um or i i do like it though they started
doing more motion capture because i
think a lot of some move filmmakers they
realize that problem
so like um josh brolin playing thanos
was actually on set with the camera gear
and thing then they were actually acting
and they were able to react with each
other right something above his head
that had his face so for the height yeah
but he's still physically there and so
they're trying to get the best of both
worlds a little bit um that's
i i quite like that that that seems to
have
um and they i mean they've done that
with other things on the jar jar winks
miso nosa was actually there and it was
but he was the actor with a big freaking
head thing on
um but we wish he had to bring up larger
geez
your subscribers
i mentioned something that is going to
really get you a lot of hate mail
go for i love hey man okay so
i like the work that mark hamill and the
team
uh
lucasfilm has done with bringing uh luke
skywalker back to like the mandalorian
and so forth
it doesn't there's there's something
missing about always been missing about
it to me and it was just this last week
that i figured out what it was
uh have you ever seen uh
george lucas's um
radio land murders
it's not a sci-fi movie it's literally
about a radio station doing kind of
tease the bell but i can't think
it is um if you look at
um
lucas's first stuff that he did thx
lemon whatever it was about the people
living underground and this in the
really crowded city and all like and
everything else you know lucas always
had this idea of like you shoot things
and you write things right up to the
point that you can't understand it
go go go go fast fast fast fast well
radio land murders
you know set in the 30s i think or the
40s and it was just about a radio
station and a murder
but it was written so i mean the the the
speed of which everything was delivered
and how the pace of the story
i mean it was just boom boom boom go go
go and
i remember you know in um
star wars uh
oh when they were on right after
leia and luke and no leia and chewie and
han solo got off a hoth but then they're
in the the the uh the belly of the beast
in the asteroid they're hiding in the
asteroid
and they go back running inside and
everything's going fast fast fast fast
you know and
solo says you know i don't have time to
discuss this committee and then leia
comes right behind him says i am not a
committee
when they did the scenes in mandalorian
and fett
luke's pace his speech pace was slow
and normal
it didn't have the frenetic oh my god
everything's on fire
kind of elements that there that there
is a trilogy had
and i think that's the thing that bob
even when he was doing the lightsaber
stuff you know in the first and last
that when he first meets uh baby yoda
rogue i mean that's frenetic but his
speech wasn't when he when he you know
takes his hood off and starts talking
it's not he doesn't have that
jazz he had and i think that's because
the cgi had to be so focused on the face
that you couldn't go ripping around and
bouncing off the ship
it's i mean yeah i i i don't know if
that was part of par that was probably
because he's supposed to sound wise and
whatever as well maybe so they slow
speech is supposed to be he's supposed
to be sound very deliberate
with the cgi we do know that the mouth
is incredibly difficult yes and if you
don't if you don't to understand how
difficult the mouth is go and watch the
very great christmas movie the the
northern express
north pole express
um
and
just look at the mouths
right
oh my god that creepy
um so
i don't know about
skywalker wanting to be so wise
in in um mandalorian i mean jesus the
rise of skywalker
i mean he's just this i mean he's still
you know even with the later series
there was no i mean he was just
angry upset oh screw you i'm gonna go i
don't know drink sea milk out of a cow
or something
you know i watched the rise of skywalker
last week um because um i got bad neck
so i've been off work for a couple of
days
um but um i got um
[Music]
it suddenly occurred to me that i'm not
sure the
um the good guys are actually the good
guys
i always forget like this is this is
going to be a bit
um oh this is a
yes i love that film soldier kurt
russell curtis has done so many great
movies over the years
and i think that was a lot of physical
experience but anyway sorry i'm
had like 84 words in that whole show
yeah he doesn't he barely says anything
it's a fantastic film um
in star wars right
so
politically speaking the bulk of the
population
is decides what that culture is than
this so you know if we have a democracy
whoever votes you know you have um
either
if everybody votes for evil
then that makes you that's your
culture's evil does that make sense so
if the most of the people want that to
be true that's what the the things you
do that's with democracy right
surely
the empire is the good guy or it's
usually the the empire is what the
people want because there's a lot of
them
and there's no
the resistance is like 12 people with a
pea shooter and
a thing and look at all the palpatine's
followers there's
hundreds of thousands of them
watching
in the circumstances
um i i'm not sure the republic are
actually the good guys
it's so like oh well
most people seem to want the empire
um and the republic turned up and went
like and and wiped them out and most
people are like i like quite like them
but they're organized and the republic
aren't very organized
um so i don't i don't know if it's just
easily more organized maybe i don't know
and but there's a lot of them it just
just occurred to me that they actually
think i'm not sure about the good guys
but he certainly is persistent
yeah
um
sean has just mentioned
do you want to hear something really sad
big trouble a little china
great movie
they're remaking it
i don't know even how that film can be
remade it makes me sad to my bones you
know there are some films that just
shouldn't
be remade apparently it might be a
sequel
which is still
but it's it's it's this is going to be a
remake there are some films that
shouldn't be remade there are rumors
this is spoiling one of my next videos
coming up
there are rumors that are going to
remake 2001 a space odyssey
amazon obviously now have control of mgm
and they want to
that went through it went through
thursday
i'm disappointed i did a video on it on
thursday
you're not keeping up with
um
there you go realize that palpatine is
evil our palpatine is a bit evil to be
fair
um
so that went through on thursday
um so that's all finalized now
um mgm apparently
want
three um big projects to push forwards
with and one of them might be stargate
one of them will be james bond they
would they want to announce a new bond
and get crack around with that
and then a third remake of something
from the archive and apparently there's
a couple of
possibilities
um but one of them is 2001 space odyssey
if there is a film that does not need to
be remade and to be honest it won't work
um
it's it's very much a film of its time
you know
the music
the style the the quite slow pace of
that movie
it won't work
and
i mean either there's there's a sequel
to 2000 there's the sequel 2010 and then
there's a sequel to that i think it's
2064.
yeah 2064. and then there's another the
final sequel to that whole series is
3001. i think our clark wrote four in
those series why not make one of those
i mean they're all good you know doesn't
need to be remade
um another one is uh war games they
might remake war games
as well which i think at the moment
politically i'm like
um but also it's actually well
terminated you could argue it was a
remake of
the third one or the fourth one was
basically remaking that but um i
actually think that that might be quite
good because
there's an element of reality to that
because then google built a quantum
computer and they actually did plug it
into the defense system
and they were like oh my god it doesn't
plug that [ __ ]
they ran simulations in this quantum
computer um
it was one in one in about 15 times they
ran a simulation that the quantum
computer kept coming up with a solution
that wiping out humanity was the way to
go
actually if we worked out humanity that
would solve all these problems and they
were saying it was alarming how often
the computer came up with the solution
before i pronounced humanity
you know what he's playing on
because these these movies
the xenomorph and alien covenant um
i think i don't think that was a cgi i
think that was the the the xenomorph in
any corners i think that was a physical
um
effect
i don't think that was cgi
um
and it was bad it was bad but it was
supposed to be like half human half
alien so it was always going to be bad i
think that was just a bad idea
um
i actually didn't hate that movie
oh i think i'm mixing it up with not
alien covenant i think i'm mixing it up
with
what was the alien movie would have been
alien four
ripley is like has been
they find
on playstation outside of federated
space
and there's like all these other
versions of when they've they had a
blood sample of her yeah they're
genetically engineered she's got acid
blood that's where she gets out this
thing she cuts herself doesn't she
winona ryder was in it
i'm not sure i've seen alien oh no alien
cover oh of course i'm being stupid on
alien covenant's the
one with the
magnetos in it
the actor that played magneto isn't it
i actually know what i didn't
particularly like that movie i found a
bit boring my mate damian you know i do
the i used to do the channel with he
thinks that's one of the greatest movies
ever made
and prometheus yeah
um
but yeah
the alien moves and that would have been
cgi wouldn't it for them
hey you know one of the we keep talking
about cgi
and this is something
that blew me away
when the uh first season of mandalorian
came out i mean i was just literally
because i just didn't know
i've been out of filmmaking for so long
you know i don't read film thread i
don't read cinematography or special
effects
i just i just don't read it
when i read that most of those
environments
were
cgi rendered on an lcd screen that the
actor was in front of
that blew me away these artists now use
the quake
the graphic system they make all of
these detailed
scenes
complete total scenes
floor
backs of the back and in the ceiling
and they call it the volume and then the
actor goes in this and they're
completely wrapped around
i didn't know that i didn't know that
was a thing that's incredible yes and uh
well because i thought i went back and i
saw you know i was watching me and
laurie know this is good this is good
that's good now see all the scenes
and like wow that's pretty good special
effects but note the the actual
visual that's on the lcd screen behind
the actor
and so now you know there's whole
companies that build these uh these uh
environments that you can just download
into your quake
system
and render it in this volume what's
called the volume this studio
and you put the actor in the middle and
there you go
like you know
normally an effect will be
anything you see out of a window is sort
of like they used to do these giant
photos didn't know or paintings yeah and
they'd be incredibly detailed they cost
hundreds of thousands of pounds these
things to produce
it's it's it's a kind of bit like so you
have a set everything in the foreground
is a set then everything in a distance
that's sort of like that one ecstasy
that's sort of like taking that
sort of theory it's just completely
they've been placed in the digital world
in a physical way which
allows them to react to it though then
yeah yeah i'll send you some links in
the technology it will just make your
jaw drop it's insane it is just insane
and i cannot pick out
which is the
the the the the scenery that somebody
made in the shop versus what's
made in quake
this is
like a gaming engine
yeah you've heard that so this is the
software they're using for these
volumes
i'd say my son's got him well there's
oculus two um vr
things
it doesn't cost particularly much but he
i i was having to play with it and it's
really really good
and it is immersive and um there's this
one thing we have to walk on a plank
and then you like fall off and it
genuinely freaked me out because the
it's it is so immersive it really is
getting to the point where you cannot
tell
the difference between
the effects and the reality i mean i i
used to be pretty good i mean i didn't
know about that but i used to be pretty
good at spotting the different types of
cgi and i i did used to read all that
stuff um
i'm getting to the point now where i'm
like i'm seeing some stuff and i'm like
i genuinely don't know how they did that
yeah and it's um you know um
i i quite like magic tricks
and i'm quite good at spotting a magic
trick and sometimes i think my wife is
like oh you're ruining it you're ruining
it i'm like no because
sometimes you know when um
when you have a magic you understand how
it works that is like even more amazing
that's like oh my god
and at my wedding this the the um
the magician did this thing where he got
a card a playing card and he tore a
corner out and then he he presented me
but then he had this block of ice and
the
the corner was in the ice and then he
sort of like broke it and thinking look
how it fits together and he'd signed it
and all this something i know exactly
how he did that you know it's all about
how you rip the card sort of thing
so i started saying that's why oh my god
i know he's done it
and she's now you ruin it
it just amazes me more
you know
when you see these things and you and
you understand the ingenuity that goes
into it
that's why i think that
well we'll wrap this up now because
we're getting it's very late here um
it's middle of the afternoon for you
you're lucky
but um
back in the day they had to be
ingenious yeah um they weren't always if
you watched films like um
oh god old what's a bad cgi movie
um let me have a think oh there's a film
over here um
oh was it called called life force
patrick stewart is in
um terrible movie it's just one
chick walking through town
that's the that's the bit that everyone
remembers british sci-fi it's best naked
chick
walking through the first 10 minutes of
the movie stuck in everyone's life force
four times back in the 80s oh my god
just make it check
yeah i i just watched the first 10
minutes of that film i've watched the
rest
um never get
eight minutes in i'm like that'll do um
but yeah
it's a terrible but special effects in
general in that movie are
awful
really bad
um
it's just lazy
there's a lot of films like that that
are just lazy and and and we're going to
have the same thing with cgi
it allows some filmmakers to be lazy
sometimes and
um
and just to be bad filmmakers and it
doesn't i think we had a comment earlier
i'm sorry i can't remember who said it
but it doesn't matter how good a special
effect is it's not going to make up for
a badly written story
yeah and it's just not you know um
look there's a but before we wrap it up
i just want to talk about some of the
things that i think are worthy that a
lot of people really don't watch and one
thing is what we'll talk about is
you know you don't have to have a big
budget to come up with a really good
movie
and
uh
robert rodriguez you know the guy that
did uh
uh the book of bogey fest
spy kids he's yeah and um
his first film he did the 16 millimeter
film
with no money called el mariachi
right
and he showed it around
to um
some friends and the the the film uh
festival circuit and it was really good
and um
that
and then of course then he got the big
budget uh movie better actors bigger
actors and he's still really good
and so but he started out with just like
nothing
so if you know people watching this you
know kids or they want to go make their
own movie
get your phone man go out and just write
something and shoot it it may be good it
may be crap but the most important thing
is you'll learn something
you'll learn something
and
some things i think a lot of people
that were pre cgi all kind of it's just
practical effects low budget
i think i mentioned before coal shack
the night stalker
from from what year was that
1974.
and i gotta admit you know i know you'll
probably disagree with this maybe but um
uh doctor who with uh tom baker though
he was really good i mean the writing in
that
era
let's let's admit it not a lot of
special effects oh no money that's all
no money
uh everybody's heard of twilight zone
but there's another series that came out
from 63 to 66 65 called outer limits
yeah we saw at limits do you see now us
it really did it a few years ago we had
a new series of influence a few schools
which was quite good yep
of course space 1999
you know
love that series
that might be coming back as well
bbc did the the uh a series on bbc um
bbc did an original series for
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
with um
simon jones and david dixon
it was so much better than the movie
i mean it was just a lot better than the
new one they did with them
the guy that played the hobbit oh his
name's gonna have
played them dr watson in sherlock holmes
as well
that guy yeah him anyways better than
that as well
that wasn't great
another good series uh back in the day
time tunnel
yeah it was just it was kind of like a
kind of like quantum leap
you know
there's the guy that did that wasn't it
because it was the same guy that
produced he'd produced time tunnel
lost in space
irwin allen
oh and alan yeah he he disagree and then
he went on to do some movies and he
became the um he did the tower inferno
didn't he and uh yeah titanic movie i
think and
another disaster movie he became the
master of disaster yeah yeah then he had
the
bomb with a lot of projects but um
yeah he did some great series about the
same time
all very similar
and there's one it was a cartoon show
for kids but it was really good science
fiction written by really good writers
that was land of the lost
not the remake from the 90s or what it
was original 74ish mid 70s
land of the lost
you know
three people on a rafting trip fall into
some sort of uh parallel universe portal
and it is kind of a mixture yeah
i'm saying
yeah
but so those are
if you're looking for something
on um
on streaming services that you look
really good sci-fi that you may have not
even know about
those
yeah most definitely
and the thing that i also watched this
week was uh turning red the pixar movie
about this little girl
coming of age film and she gets her
first period and she also turns into a
red panda
yeah
the woke people have got quite angry
about that movie i haven't seen it yet
but i will watch it at some point um i
don't have children that are the age so
i actually have to watch that on my own
so
yeah here i don't know about
the the world crowd but here it's the
conservative christians that's just lost
their damn mind it seems to be the same
people but i might be i might be being a
different they tend not to be the most
woke people in the world you know it
seems like those would be two different
demographics but you know i don't know
maybe it is but
you know if i look at my facebook uh
feed it's you know when i see hateration
on that it's always coming from you know
joe bob's baptist church of
swampland louisiana do we need to see a
cartoon about a girl getting a period
well not really but it wasn't
about 30 seconds of the movie the mom's
trying to get okay here's your ibuprofen
here's your food here's your water
bottle here's your pads large medium
white super wide oh you know
and then and then the girl is a just a
big bear
yeah that poker night does have a good
point there that there are there are bad
cgi there's great cgi there's bad
practical effects there's good practical
effects it's true i think
to wrap this up i'll talk to you about
um
i'll talk to you about um awoke comment
that i had a couple of days ago but just
to read that
to wrap up the war movies better i don't
think they were
i think practical effects
the david cameron point we made about
films like the abyss
is the perfect example where they know
when to use practical effects remember
there are practical effects in um
in uh trusted park
you know the bit where they lean on the
trisource it's poorly that's a model
it's um you know
um it's it's it's using them well and
it's when they don't use them well is
the problem whether they're practical
effects or cgi or anything it's how
they're used isn't it and cgi is just a
tool
then it's a tool that sometimes used
brilliantly and sometimes used really
really badly
um
so so yeah i would agree with that
um
nothing wrong with cgi just how they use
it for everything now tom hang on
yeah i think a lot of those people use
cgi to fix mistakes
yeah
while we wormed our way into this
you know exposition hole and so now we
got to fix it with
cgi sparklers or you know a scale or you
know yeah
we'll just go back this is this is our
topic now we're doing that topic
conversation i'd love to talk about that
i just want to ask you this question and
i guess and this is
basically i had a chat um we then had a
long chat afterwards about it
but his initial comment sort of concerns
me a little bit and it was basically
saying that lord of the rings
is um woke crap
so i sort of said well why i said well
there's a black dwarf doesn't that tell
you everything
we then had a long conversation about
that in the in any he wasn't coming from
a racist point of view he was coming
from a they were never they were never
black dwarfs before so why are there now
and it there was a much bigger thing
that he was actually thinking but
but that initial comment
stinks he's got a point
or is that just a massive over
simplification or should we do this by
comments like that well i may be biased
um i first got interested in lord of the
rings i think in like hobbit
during first grade
uh lived in west virginia and somebody
wrote on the spray painted on the top of
the town's water tower frodo lives
apparently that was a big thing back in
the 60s riding on your water tower
so i went to the library to figure out
what that was
and so they handed me they told me about
the hobbit
so it took my took me forever to beg my
grandmother to buy me a copy and it took
forever to read that i mean as a first
grader took me forever to read that book
but i got through it and it was just oh
my god oh there's more i've got to read
those so i've always been a big tolkien
fan probably my
favorite author
and i've i've got when i've got all my
stuff unpacked i have a bookshelf
literally full of tolkien's books and
movies and paraphernalia and tarot cards
and everything you can imagine for
that's related to uh tolkien's work
he never really mentioned the color of
dwarves
i mean they were actually black hobbits
though
yes i think
some foot something yeah
the uh he did mention that uh gage
galadriel was fair
you know that could be
white to me they were all supposed to be
black we don't know we'll have to ask
tolkien
it just made me think about that because
um at the weekend i went to see harry
potter the live show in london it's very
good one of the reasons why i pushed the
show back late today because we were
like getting back oh okay um the train
um bloody trains um but in in that
hermione
is not a little white girl anymore she's
a little black girl
um
and so is hagrid
um so i mean and i did think that was a
bit
they've obviously just wanted to put
some colour into it i'm gonna gotta be
so careful with this subject and not not
to say it the wrong way
um but they did that that felt a bit
like they've just done that on just for
the sake of it
um
well i mean you know jk rowling
she was um
maybe not the wokest person in the world
but she said you know she never wrote a
color in for hermione she just described
her as having crazy hair
really bushy hair that was it that was
the only real description
so no harm no foul really amazing
it was a little surprising and when we
watched it because we have you know we
have this idea but then actually if you
think about it there's a lot of lots of
black people in harry potter in the
films
um so
hey here's a solution but um yeah that i
say like comments like that i think come
out a lot
um
where they
which is an oversimplification of a
bigger problem and it's something that i
don't know
leaves a bad taste in my mouth i think
it in you know if a a
black person is playing something that
most people imagine as a white role
and it's like something i want to you
know like uh something out of tolkien
for example that i always want to see i
don't care
give me more tolkien you know i mean
do it with puppets do it with naked
puppets as long as it's talking come on
you know seriously i don't care i'm a
talking freak
yeah
there you go
i'm not i don't care about the series
we'll see i'll watch you when it comes
out i just i just disannoy even when
people go so crazy about lord of the
rings that it's going to be woken on
since i'm just like it hasn't been
released yet
i don't even think if they finished
making it yet
let's calm down or do it watch it
um and then then we'll hate it but let's
watch it then hate it
you know in there's this also woke
discussion around the whole token and
power of the rings thing is like well
tolkien always described the good people
as white and the bad people the quarks
the goblins the uruk high as black
worm tongue was white and he was
absolutely evil
sour man the white
evil
totally evil
[Music]
i mean gollum schizophrenic and
evil
ah here we go i think
our friend he needs to get apple tv
doesn't he
yes dude uh yeah
quick review of that
excellent
i was wondering how they were going to
do the long term
process of i mean
the story takes takes place over a very
long period of time
i'm not going to spoil it for you but
it's very good i really didn't like the
way they did that following up on
another comment we saw
the known space series by larry niven uh
i'm thinking that's the one that
includes our uh
ring world
and also the human
zen wars i'm waiting for that you know
i'd really like to see that
i understood somebody starting to make
is doing pre-production on rendezvous
with rama
needs to be done
so yeah there's just some again we're in
a position where there's some really
great sci-fi coming out and
yeah fantastic yeah um just so just to
be clear with for dragon and then the
first series of foundation is on apple
tv now and i think is the second series
about to start
production
i think in the summer early yeah i think
it's just about to be made yeah
um someone just mentioned in there
the sarah connor chronicles do you
remember that it got cancelled did you
get two seasons and it got cancelled
i haven't seen one episode i'm done i
know it's on streaming service someplace
but i want to watch it it's very good
you should watch it the terminator is
river from uh summer glau from
firefly who was excellent in it
the sort of human from the future sort
of character
was um one of the chaps from 90210 and
he was um
i don't remember his name but he was
actually brilliant
it was really well written um and it was
a shame it got cancelled when it did
because it was just you know when the
shows were just really getting in their
legs
yeah really is it really was a shame
that that show got cancelled when it did
it was the next one if you get chance
definitely give it
um right we will call it an evening
thank you everybody that's got into the
comments tonight you've been fantastic
um
unless you know this protector is a film
yeah that would be good
i'm sure they'll think of them they'll
do that at some point
um
yeah you guys have been fantastic
tonight i cannot wait to see what you
come up with next week as always if you
have any ideas for things that you would
like us to have a chat about get into
the comments and tell us because we
can't think of anything now so and we
always think of something um but but
yeah if you if you've got stuff you
really want to talk about we'd love to
have your comments so please let me know
or get on the facebook page just a
sidetrack and you can let us know
go and find stormy on um cyworks his
channel and um subscribe and i
will put a link in the description
oh thank you so much
for like an hour and a half so please
i might have forgotten um but um but
i'll do it in a minute um and it's
always on the facebook page and it's
done over on all the live shares but
everyone guys please goodnight as always
stay safe and um
my cousin from america
he's not because
thanks again mate
very welcome take care we'll see you in
two weeks already bye-bye guys